et les chiffres je veux le dire sont ces
colosses avait
regardé
avec 70 passages radio en moyenne chaque
jour les titres de jean jacques goldman
sont parmi les plus diffusés grâce à
cela selon nos estimations l'artiste
toucherait près de 2 millions d'euros
chaque année rien qu'en droit d'auteur
mais en bon gestionnaire jean jacques
goldman a également bien ficelé son
contrat avec sa maison de disques car
lorsque d'autres artistes doivent se
contenter de 8 % de royalties lui
perçoit 25 % sur chaque disque vendu
avec 28 millions de disques écoulés
l'artiste aurait gagné une centaine de
millions d'euros depuis ses débuts un
patrimoine géré depuis des années 90 par
son frère robert une immense fortune qui
n'a jamais fait tourner la tête de
l'artiste
[Musique]
demers
[Applaudissements]
il ya quelques années quand j'avais
son nom j'ai racheté
gérer plus du tout géré acheter un
appartement qui appartenait à john mann
et c'est son frère qui a signé pas vu
que c'est le modèle qui gère sa fortune
et son appartement était surtout ta
c'est assez simple on est très agile et
tour au fait de daniel ruch quel prix et
vous l'avez acheté alors je l'avais
acheté je vous dis que je dis tous et à
bientôt j'ai acheté à l'époque deux
millions quatre cent mille euros
c'était pas non plus quand même un
appartement simple en théorie on tient
jusqu'au bout
qui dit
j'ai quand même chercher parce que j'ai
cherché partout dans ma part ce n'est
pas une petite partition des fois que
j'aurai plus
non il m'a rien d'essayer un matelas et
bien matlab il a dormi que j'ai trouvé
que j'ai gardées amoureusement que
j'avais j'ai fait encadrer et c'est
devenu une oeuvre d'art
295 très grand juste pour lui expliquer
pour ses revenus donc chaque année il ya
un organisme qui s'appelle la sacem
kirdis ligne des droits d'auteur aux
auteurs et compositeurs jean la goldman
est évidemment compositeur et c'est au
prorata des chansons qui sont diffusées
stade plus vos chansons sont diffusés
plus vous avez droit d'auteur hélas ces
chansons sont tellement diffusé que
c'est un calcul à pour eux il a un
forfait dont on a parlé donc 2 millions
d'euros par an et quel que soit le
nombre de chansons diffusées il lui
donne cette somme qui est énorme et ça
pas forcément fait ses incalculables ça
passe tellement de l'amslp comme on
l'avait dit à céline dion il ya plein
d'autres tubes d'autres artistes est
donc pour lui c'est un forfait il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont concernés par
cette règle aussi david guetta par
exemple non mais c'est vrai qu'en radio
enfin toi qui travaille aussi en radio
bernard jean jacques goldman ça passe
une heure on a un jean jacques goldman
et on effectivement parce qu on a aussi
des chansons qu'il a écrites il a
composé quand même je te promets il a
composé l'envi il a composé aussi mais
je suis belle pour patrice est un carton
pâte